tell us what's what's happened ever
since we sat down with you and michael
uh with the mafia states of america
well a lot of things the all my
following everybody's asking me when it
comes out when it's going to come out
and all this other stuff
so i tell them soon and
but
everything is going well
and we're getting a lot of calls from
everybody different companies different
people from all over the place
and
i think the three days we spent there
with the interview some of them were a
little rough i think
i got a little excited a couple of times
but uh i think it went well
i think it went very well i thought
there was a great team put together my
team came down
they loved it they enjoyed it
i mean
i think i have a different different
image
of
michael really yeah i do i have a
different image of him
you know meeting his family and and him
and
i think he's a lot more honest than i
thought originally
and
i got to like him
very interesting did you think that was
going to be the case because when you
and i talked the first time for a couple
hours you were like there's no way in
the world i'm going to do this and then
a couple years later you ended up doing
it your expectation going in
versus what ended up happening do those
two align or did you think it was going
to be slightly different
i didn't know what it was going to be
like i'll tell you the truth michael's a
racket there's no question about it he
was a money-maker for the family he did
that russian thing he said he started he
actually started
but
the russians did it they used us it was
in a very intelligent move that they did
and they came to us with this [ __ ]
protect us and do this and do that
they came to us for one reason we had
connections all over the city of new
york
we could put them in hundreds of gas
stations with their guests
and desk camp and they gave us money but
they gave us that [ __ ] story were
scared take care of us
they didn't need us to take care of us
they needed us to get gas stations
so there was a lot of stories and he was
one of the first people they went to
i think his father's reputation and name
made them go to him
and
he was very successful with it
but like we talked about in the in the
thing i think i'm a gangster and a
little bit of a racketeer i think people
agree with that
and he's more of a
racketeer
which is not a shame there's no shame to
that but and i think he believes in a
lot of things is religion
i questioned that a couple of times
but i think uh
you know some people change their life
and believe it
some people don't
but i think he's
told the truth so i changed my mind a
little bit this whole thing did
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]